enfin quand on me l'a dit l'indicé c'est
lourd des plaques dont pour moqueries
répéter menaces violences sept cent
mille élèves de la primaire au lycée
serait victime de harcèlement un mâle
présent à l'école mais aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux qui peut mener à la
dépression et même au suicide
alerté par ce fléau maxime lycéens à
villepreux est devenu ambassadeur contre
le harcèlement
depuis un an il sensibilise ses
camarades il y avait une case seconde où
je suis passé où il y avait un cas de
harcèlement d'un élève et s'est avéré
que que cette classe a vraiment réussi à
prendre conscience sur le harcèlement
est aujourd'hui quand on voit cette
élève qui étaient harcelées pour sur des
motifs assez physique ou voilà il est on
le sent déjà plus en confiance
comme lui une centaine de lycéens
souhaitent devenir ambassadeur à
villiers saint frédéric
ils ont participé à une journée de
formation organisée par le centre
académique d'appui aux écoles et aux
établissements et par l'académie de
versailles rôle d'un ambassadeur c'est
d'avoir des éléments clés sur la
thématique du harcèlement donc de savoir
ce qu'il ya derrière le harcèlement le
la victime et l'auteur finalement qui a
uni
d'une certaine manière est aussi victime
white et victimes abandonnées
comment on peut l'aider comment on peut
l'accompagner l'idée c'est ça c'est de
les amener à être acteur en fait auprès
de leurs camarades et pas seulement
spectateurs je trouve que c'est plus
fréquent qu'on qu'on le pense est
vraiment faim moi j'avais pas les outils
nécessaires pour voir agir et je
trouvais ça vraiment que grâce à ça
maintenant on est au courant et dès
qu'on est face à un cas de harcèlement
on peut agir un soutien plus que
nécessaire et seulement 4% des élèves
victimes de harcèlement le signal de
même